hey skill braces but today we're gonna
play some more tricky truck because you
bros really liked it
and I I love this game it's my favorite
so happy uh no it's a lot of fun
can't you see we're having fun already
we're having fun right let's play twice
Steve windy we're gonna play on hard
because that's what I am okay here we go
yes I have no idea where I'm going why
is life so tricky this is just like real
life except not at all oh my [ __ ] sake
alright let's do that again
no prob let's go kya sorry very fun boy
prably right wha
I barely touched it this is for Sweden
this is for my mother line
funny handling back that I'm still alive
I hate my life come on first haha here
we go look at this [ __ ] boy make a right
oh my god oh my god I need more speed
need for speed Big D cell come here you
son of a [ __ ]
yes ah I don't know where I'm going
that's not fair [ __ ] that [ __ ] it's the
wise man once said if it doesn't work
the first try or the second try or the
third try
well you're probably not that good and
you should probably just quit
yeah nope oh I don't want to feel now
please please oh we lost a little
package it's okay it's okay
No huh huh huh mom made it
I'm alive yes but funny Harry Bettis jab
la bola met
oh but Rock Mountain yes on hard baby
Messi Michalik Matthew Maskell but fetes
Matthew this car [ __ ] sucks man here
we go
yeah boy
that I do it ramp off the roof that
sounds above what you can't just kill me
stop hello I can see myself in there in
the mirror look at that face that's a
face of a man who gets a lot of [ __ ] do
you see this [ __ ] bro do you [ __ ] see
this [ __ ] breath here we go Oh help I'm
scared mom I'm scared
what the [ __ ] is happening aah keep
going keep pushing captain keep pushing
I can see the head captain no no let's
try that again here we go keep going
keep going captain captain totes keep
going law nope
balance are out block Oh
we go in there ah ah ah [ __ ]
I didn't even crush myself that's
impossible come on do you see do you see
it just no way no way there's no there's
no way
there's no way in hell stop sliding like
a [ __ ] beer oh god okay okay
tennis ball tennis buh
goodbye tennis ball Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you
oh [ __ ]
oh you're gonna do this [ __ ] here we go
here we go the [ __ ] like what the [ __ ]
man let's try this with another car oh
this game is actually fun it's weird how
I'm enjoying myself with this piece of
[ __ ]
oh I'm so close boom let's go straight
for it oh my god are you [ __ ] kidding
me
no oh nine eight that's right that's not
oh my god are you serious oh [ __ ] okay
it's okay
oh my god oh my god keep going oh this
is so confusing Wow there we go that's
it stop it right there buster
captain captain their radius kept in
their radius good job
God not not another one oh I can just oh
oh well it all makes sense now doesn't
it
I just wait for my turning life oh god
don't crash help Taylor Taylor do
something Taylor oh god ah [ __ ] this is
not part of the plan ah come on
Oh what camera angles am i oh I did it
with my breasts off for [ __ ] sake
another one what is this no oh I got a
park there yeah yeah yeah come on
ah this is so confusing
ah yeah no wow I completed the back and
my microphone is in my eye like a cyborg
PewDiePie that's probably why I was so
good at the game oldest son
very good after that episode they're
like if you enjoyed us always thank you
so much for watching click here to watch
more similar videos and I'll see you
bros in the next one sales seeing the
look on your face
Hey look at that still going strong
never mind
haha come on Jerry don't be a little
[ __ ] it's for my homeland this is for
Sweden nice is for this is for my
homeland Thanks